cleaner air and more jobs to things that
everybody wants but what happens when
those goals collide this is not a
business this is a lifestyle if you own
a truck you drive it all day you better
be working on it when it ain't working
so your weekends are devoted to keeping
this piece of equipment legal and safe
Dewayne Whitney is co-owner of crooks
trucking in Cypress California when the
company started there was just one truck
now there are 18 and 20 employees but
that's about to change
California and carbs say that truck is
killing people what do you say carve is
the California Air Resources Board a
state agency that's imposing new
regulations on diesel particulates a
type of pollution that is emitted from
buses and trucks a truck to replace
today would be two hundred thousand
dollars in a few years Whitney's entire
fleet will be illegal you just can't
pick a death date that everybody at one
whack it's done carb agents inspect
trucks looking for violations the agency
claims that diesel particulate pollution
contributes to 2000 premature deaths in
California each year but it's the number
accurate what I'm contending is the
number should be closer to zero
UCLA epidemiologist dr. James instrum
authored a 2005 study that found no
relationship between particulate
pollution and premature death at the
time when I published it and still true
today it's the largest most detailed
study on the relationship between fine
particulate air pollution and total
mortality that's ever been published
carb officials were gathering scientific
evidence that would guide their
decisions on air quality regulations so
instrum submitted his study to the
agency and basically it was ignored if I
was to use one thing a word it would
just be unprofessional I think it was
not handled the way that you would
expect an objective review group to look
at evidence but the process kept moving
along and carb was preparing to issue
strict new regulations on buses and
trucks as I went along in this process
my frustration level
just kept growing the new regulations
were to be justified by a study issued
by carb the way it was presented just
didn't show the kind of scientific rigor
that one would expect on an issue that
has this much importance to the
California economy when instrum looked
at an early version of the report he
grew suspicious he started looking into
the credentials of the lead author dr.
Qian Tran and discovered something
interesting didn't have the PhD in
statistics from UC Davis that he claimed
several of us just raised the red flag
this is a serious matter
carb chairperson Mary Nichols I did not
comprehend for my fellow board members
about this issue board members voted for
the stringent new regulations
recommended by the Tran report before
Nicholls made trans deception in public
and although initially he denied it he
finally admitted that all that he did
have a PhD but it was from a non
recognized institution he did have a PhD
from Cornell University it was purchased
in 2007 for $1000 Thornhill University
is an online diploma mill he forfeited
two months of salary and was demoted all
I can say is I apologize instrum
instance the scientists who advised the
voting members of carb were not being
cycled in and out as required by law
case in point
John Froines who pushed hard for diesel
regulations was removed as chairman of
the advisory panel after an strim
publicized the issue but by that time
Froines had already held the position
for 26 years it's important because
they're not getting the full range of
scientific expertise it gets that exists
in California instrum says keeping the
same people in the same positions for so
long helps shut out scientists who don't
think stringent new regulations are
justified what you work for your whole
life you wake up one day and somebody
says you know you can't do this anymore
instead of buying new trucks Whitney
could comply with the new regulations by
buying new muffler
this unit here is $15,000 that truck the
way it sits today because the death date
on it is probably worth $5,000 $5,000
that's the value of the rims and tires
the only parts of the truck worth
anything to a potential buyer you're
spending and whitney says the mufflers
are unreliable you are gambling with
with your business
new carb rules are basically going to
put me out of business
in the world we live in you can't really
separate science from politics and
that's very very unfortunate the money
that researchers need to do their
research comes from agencies they'd have
to generate that money on the basis of
frequently public fears
professor Robert Phelan is co-director
of the air pollution health effects lab
at UC Irvine so we see public fears
being exploited in order to maintain the
funding to agencies falen notes that
today California's air is much cleaner
than it was in the 60s and 70s and he
credits carb regulations with helping
make that happen but few people realize
how much air quality has improved so
it's very difficult for a researcher to
come out and say something is a less
lesser risk than the public police the
agency has sort of taken on a life of
its own they're going to be on the
forefront of regulations whether the in
fact the regulations are science-based
or not instruments that research that
has come out since his 2005 study
generally agrees with his study it's
actually consistent with the great body
of evidence yet UCLA did not come to n
streams defense in fact in February 2010
UCLA officials told him that after 34
years at the University he was now out
of a job what's happened to dr. instrum
I think is bad news for scientists in
general the engine of innovation
progress and ideas depends at a very
deep and fundamental level on academic
freedom
Adam Kissel of fire the foundation for
individual rights in education which is
defending dr. instrum in his fight to
keep his job if dr. Antrim loses his job
because he has expressed his academic
freedom then it's a message to other
researchers that you better not rock the
boat because you might be next
we asked UCLA officials to come on
camera but they declined opting instead
to send an email which says they can't
comment on quote a confidential personal
matter however dr. instrum has waived
his confidentiality and privacy rights
in this matter his record is open for
review by anyone UCLA has made various
claims against n strim for instance they
said there was no longer money to fund
his position but later the money
materialized they said his research was
not aligned with the mission of his
department but then that charge was
dropped my guess is they didn't really
think this through very clearly and
didn't have a specific evidence the
environmental regulation machine is
powerful in California when dr. instrum
went up against that machine he was
retaliated against retaliated against
says Kissel for publishing politically
incorrect research and for shaking
things up at carb Mary Nichols the head
of carb was also a professor at UCLA as
is John Froines who lost his powerful
position at carb after n streams whistle
blowing in fact Froines is the most
powerful person in instrument apartment
and one who voted to lay him off and I
have felt very intimidated by this
process and to me the worst thing is to
not consider the cost of meeting new
regulations people are unemployed the
economy is hurt that hits public health
very very hard
I took my hard-earned money and invested
it in something that was supposed to
make me money and last me a lifetime
now I wake up the lifetimes over
there's gonna be an awful lot of truck
drivers looking for work Mary Nichols
declined our interview request
in an April 4th hearing will determine
whether dr. instrum keeps his job but
the final decision rests with UCLA
Chancellor Jeanne block for reason TV
i'm ted bellacor